[音楽]
皆さんは日常生活の中でアートに触れる
場面はありますかここ10年を振り返って
もその機会はどんどん増えているような
体感がありますではアートとは
誰が何の目的で
作るものなのか今日はこれをテーマにお話
をさせていただきます
僕はコネルというチームで30を超える
職種の
クリエイターと活動をしています
普段は
様々な
企業から依頼を受けて
ブランドを生み出したりもしくは
未来のサービスを作るための研究開発を
行っているんですが最近は
仲間たちとアート作品を作って発表する
ことが増えましたどんな
作品かと言いますとあり得るかもしれない
未来を
先取るそのような
体験型の作品です
実際に体験をしてくださった方々からよく
質問を受けることがあるんですがどこの
美大を卒業されたんですかというようなご
質問ですねなんですが僕はもともと理工学
部の出身ですそして大学を卒業した後は
アメリカに本社を置く
コンサルティングファームでものすごく
ロジカルなお仕事に取り組んでいました
そんな僕がなぜ今
仲間たちとアートを作っているのか
具体的にお伝えするために
作品を一つ
紹介させてください
2022年の夏
東京に立ち上げた
ノウハ買取センターです
この機会が
作品の中で実際に使っていた
ノウハの
自動買取器ですちょっと使ってみましょう
はいこのようにですね中から
脳波の計測器を
取り出しましておでこに
ぴったりと装着しますそして100秒間の
間何か特定のことを考え続けてもらいます
我々はそのノウハウを1000円で
買い取ります
このように100円玉が10枚出てくると
いうような取引になりますそして
ノウハデータをですね
我々が独自に開発をしたアルゴリズムに
よって
絵画に変換をします100秒間試行してい
たことがそのまま
絵画のタイトルになってそしてクラウド上
に登録され
世界中どこからでも購入ができるように
なります
ちなみにこの絵は僕が
リンゴに関して100秒間
考えていた時の
脳波絵画になります
ポイントはですね
赤ん坊であろうが
政治家であろうがどんな人からでも100
秒間1000円という
同じ価格で等しく買い取るということです
そしてタイトルと
絵画の
美しさを踏まえて
僕たちの主観で
絵画の値段を決めているというところが
ポイントになりますだいたいですが
5,000円から2万円程度の
幅で値段をつけていますこういった一連の
活動を通して一つの作品として発表したの
が買取センターです
でここでテーマに戻りますアートとは誰が
何の目的で作るものなのか
脳波買取センターの場合は
僕たちがこう仲間と
会話している中で飛び出した妄想が
きっかけでした
ノウハウを売買する未来がやってくるん
じゃないかとこういった妄想です
すごくあり得る未来だなというふうに
直感でピンと来たことをよく覚えています
で次の瞬間からですねこの妄想を試したく
てそして未来の可能性を検証してみたくて
しょうがなくなってしまいましたでこの
妄想を
検証するという手段はいろいろあって
例えば
論文を書いてみたり
SF小説に落とし込んでみたり
映画で未来を表現するということもできた
かもしれません
でも僕たちは
実際にどんな人々が
反応してくれるのか
実際にこの目で見て
確かめてみたかったという思いが強かった
ので
脳波買取センターという
未来の会社組織をイメージして空間を
作り込みそしてお金というメディアを
通じて人々と取引を行うこの検証方法を
選びました
結果10日間で1000名を超える方々に
来場いただき
合計で100万円を超える
ノウハウを買い取ることができました
会場にはいろんな方がいらっしゃって
脳波を売って手に入れたお金で
自分の絵画作品を買う方がいたり
他の方の絵画作品を買う人がいて
自動販売機で
ジュースを買う人がいたり何も
買わずにそのままお金を持って帰って行か
れる方がいたり
様々な光景が見られました
最も多く
来てくれた方は20回以上の列に並んで
ノウハウを売ってくれましたそして70歳
を超えるおばあちゃんや小学生も
ノウハウ売ってくれました
SNSでは
賛否が
きっぱりと分かれて
顔の見えない方々があれやこれやと
いろんなコメントを
残して
くれていました
本当にセミが鳴くような
真夏の熱い日々でしたが
わざわざ電車賃を払って
数時間も並んで
ノウハウを売ってくれる人たちがたくさん
いましたそのほとんどが
知り合いではなく
初めてお会いする方々だったので人々は
ノウハウを売るということに大きな興味と
期待を持っているんだなと
実感することができましたさてここで再び
テーマに立ち返りますがアートとは何
でしょうか
まず第一に自己表現であるということは
間違いありません
では
良いアートとは何でしょうか高い
値段で
売られる作品のことでしょうかそれとも
美術館で取り扱われるような作品のこと
でしょうか
はたまた
SNSでバズる作品でしょうか
どれも間違っていませんしどれもいいなと
思います
でも僕たちがアートを作る目的は
自らの妄想がどれぐらいあり得る未来なの
かを
検証するために
社会から反応を得ることです
ノウハウを買い取るためには出費はあり
ましたがこの作品は僕たちにとってとても
いいアートになりました
脳波を売買する未来はあり得ると
確信を
得て目的を達成できたからですそしてこの
アートの活動はさらに大きな副産物を生ん
でくれました
新たな仲間たちです
妄想に共感する
企業の方やもしくは研究者の方々が海を
越えてつながってくれています
例えば
こっちの脳波系測器を使った方がいいん
じゃないかとか
脳波の規格
絵画を
NFTにして
ネタバース上で販売してみないかとか
未来のジュースの自販機ってもしかしたら
お金でもなくカードでもなく
脳波で購入できるようになるんじゃないか
といろんなアイデアをいただいてます
新たに生まれていくこのようなつながりを
通して
未来を実現させるスピードがさらに
早めていけるんじゃないかと
ワクワクしています
もし2022年に
脳波買取センターを実施していなければ
こういった専門的な話題が
ラボを飛び出してさらに
オープンな
形で議論されるようになるタイミングは
もっと
後になってしまっていたかもしれないと
思うとあと
通じて
社会と対話ができたということに大きな
意義を感じていますでは最後にこの
エピソードを通してお伝えしたいことを3
つにまとめます1つ目
誰でもアートを作ることができます
アーティストが作る作品がアートなのでは
なく
新しさを表現する人がアーティストです
私はアーティストじゃないから私が作る
ものはアートじゃないというふうに
自分を抑制する必要はありません
2つ目
経営者や新規事業の担当者など
未来を妄想する立場にいる人はハートと
いう手法を通じて
体験を提供し
社会と対話することをお勧めします
企画書や論文では得られないような
生々しい反応が得られるはずです
3つ目
アートは
必ずしも一人で作り上げる必要はありませ
んもしあなたが
絵を描くのが苦手でも
妄想を発信することによって
知り合いのデザイナーが反応してくれたり
もしくはインターネットを通して
エンジニアとつながることができるかも
しれません
あなたの妄想に共感してくれる人と
共に作り上げることはとても
エキサイティングなことです
僕たちからのメッセージは
以上です